Free People of free country it's been 10
days since we started our war and fight
10th day of hard work
one long night that doesn't give us any
rest today is a Saturday
during the war Saturday doesn't mean
anything it
Monday Tuesday Wednesday all of these
days are the same days
because we defend our country we save
our people
our country doesn't have any weekends
anymore
and it doesn't matter what day
or date it is
I spoke to Emmanuel macron the French
President last night and to Polish
president Mr Duda we speak every day and
I'm grateful to every single one of them
for the
support I'm grateful
to Andrew's wife
and I believe they are our friends our
polish friends we managed to avoid the
humanitarian crisis on the or on the
border and
thousands of um Ukrainian women
managed to get assistance
nobody asks what their nationality is
and we practically have no border with
Poland now because uh it's now not time
for having borders
and I hope we will be able to say soon
to our people come back from Poland
Hungary Romania because it's safe now
and you can come back we're already
thinking about our future all ukrainians
how we're going to rebuild our cities
our economy I spoke to the head of the
International Bank to the head of the
international monetary fund
and other International financial
institutions about support to Ukraine
there are already decisions made to
provide
assistance to Ukraine after the war and
these are only the first steps first
decisions I spoke to the president of
Turkey
uh to a United Arab Emirates
I spoke to the head of European Council
I spoke to the head of the EU
to the president of the EU and I'm
grateful to many many people who are
everywhere in the world
britslava Leon Paris
different people in different cities
came out into the streets to support
Ukraine I'm grateful to Americans
and to support of um people
just regular Americans who support
regular ukrainians who demand
increase in sanctions against the
aggressor right now who demand
no-fly zone in Ukraine right now 74 of
Americans are for no-fly zone 74
absolute majority what else do you need
to approve a decision about it
and we hope for the same result in other
European countries
our Armed Forces do their best to hold
on and protect
dunbar's key of cherni give other places
and
we do everything we can
so that Russian soldiers see what we can
do something they didn't see in their
worst nightmares
foreign
thousand soldiers already died
the soldiers who didn't even have an
opportunity to understand why they were
in a foreign country what for they were
fighting nobody explained them that to
them
Ukrainian
people
resisted and still resists everywhere
even in those areas where the occupiers
managed to come through
our people resist they pick up their
national flag and show
to the soldiers of Russia that we we
will win
and
they
still
have their dignity Ukrainian people
still keep fighting
we managed to get an agreement
to provide assistance to those cities in
Ukraine that are in the dire and worst
situation
to save
children and women and older people to
provide medication and food to those who
stay there in those places
and those people willing to leave these
places should be able to do so now using
the humanitarian corridor
but those who can should continue
fighting we do everything we can on our
side to make sure that this agreement
works
regarding the humanitarian corridors and
we will see if we can move even further
about our negotiations with Russia